Bellco experiment comes to us from the
director of wolf creek and the darkness
and is written by James Gunn of
guardians of the galaxy Fame this film
is about 80 employees in a small office
building
suddenly large metal doors surround the
building and a voice comes over the
intercom saying if you guys don't kill a
certain amount of people while we're
going to kill double that amount have
fun and from that moment on we have the
purge meets battle royale meets The
Hunger Games meets office space I guess
and John C McKinley is even in it all we
need is Milton to kill somebody with his
stapler and it's my stapler
don't touch my stapler I'm gonna kill
you with my stapler but and I said I
don't care if they lay me off either
because I told I told bill that if they
move my desk one more time than the
accident I'm quitting I'm going to quit
I have a really good friend who's a
fantastic screenwriter who often likes
to joke about the pitch movie now to him
a pitch movie is you walk into an office
and you say what if we made Beauty and
the Beast except the Beast is the
predator you guys get what I'm saying
whoever made under siege back in the day
with Steven Seagal probably walked into
an office and said what if we made die
hard except on a boat
the Belko experiment is a fantastic
pitch movie it's a great concept you can
walk into an office and say hey for five
million dollars I'll get you guys your
money back let's do this idea about a
bunch of people in an office and they're
forced to kill each other ok that's an
easy sell James Gunn's writing it he's a
big name now because of guarding to the
galaxy let's do it and that's what I
like the most about this movie is the
concept to pitch the social study of
what will you do if you feel like you're
forced to do something that you know is
wrong will you pull that trigger will
you try to defend yourself or will you
allow your morals to do the right thing
in this horrific moment I loved that
idea and after leaving the belk of
experiment I can tell you that I
basically just saw an extremely gory
grindhouse version of that idea that had
barely anything to say and did virtually
every uninteresting thing you could have
done with this situation at
every single turn the movie has an
opportunity to do something creative
even if you can't get creative with your
idea the movie has tons of opportunities
to make creative kills or make at least
that aspect of the movie fun satirical
light-hearted maybe a little enjoyable
perhaps in the know but at every single
turn the movie chooses the less creative
route and just goes for a bunch of
deaths that really had no impact and in
the long run the movie just kind of ends
with the most on the note setup for a
sequel I've seen since Independence Day
resurgence when they actually have an
entire scene dedicated to setting up a
sequel this movie has a moment where
you're just like oh so there's going to
be another one I guess okay do I have a
say I love James Gunn as a writer I like
slither guardians of the galaxy the
movie super is extremely entertaining
and kind of disgusting but it's
different
I really admire him as a writer and I
think that his screenplay here had
possibilities there's something I'm
going to be talking about pretty soon
when I started doing my alien reviews
when it comes to Alien Resurrection the
screenplay that Joss Whedon wrote for
Alien Resurrection is basically on
screen according to Whedon his
screenplay was pretty much preserved
on-screen his ideas his plotting his
dialogue but the director of Alien
Resurrection took his screenplay which
was more of a fun light-hearted tone and
turned it into a very serious movie and
so suddenly these two tones writer and
director what they were both going for
didn't work the Belko experiment feels
like it should have been a more
lighthearted film despite the fact that
it is a rather terrifying idea there
should have been a dose of satirical
edge to this film a dose of humor maybe
just a slight ray of sunshine in this
horrific situation the way the film is
helmed is so over-the-top and serious
and I get it you know I can understand
why if you look at the screenplay you
could say okay this is a really
horrifying terrible situation but the
film doesn't do anything creative
I must go back to that the entire idea
of this film is a great idea it's just
that it's told in the most bland way
that you could possibly imagine
and even if they were just going to go
for a movie that's just about the kills
the kills are boring there are times I
don't want get into spoilers but they
just kind of they just kind of fucking
line people up and that's that's it I
mean there's a few moments where you're
like okay that's some really impressive
prosthetics but overall even that aspect
of the movie I don't think is going to
please even the most bloodthirsty genre
fan because I love horror movies they're
kind of my thing if they're done right
and this film had so many good ideas and
it just about every turn they choose the
more bland route I honestly had more fun
talking about this movie with my friend
who I saw it with then I did watching
the movie because both of us agreed that
it was a fantastic idea there was a good
film in here somewhere
it was just waiting to blossom but the
way they go about telling the story is
so routine and there's just nothing you
can really take away from it in the end
except for the idea that they want to
make more as I was watching it I was
thinking this is ok it feels kind of
like something that John Carpenter would
have made in like the early 70s like an
assault on precinct 13 just this very
gory grindhouse film that is just
completely balls-to-the-wall who gives a
shit let's just have some fun but along
the way the film gets increasingly bleak
and increasingly cynical to the point
where the film really has nothing to say
and it's a movie that's kind of about a
social experiment with nothing to say
that's not good
the film also has an absurd amount of
red herring it follows one character for
the entire film who's like this side
character they keep cutting back to and
it really goes nowhere in the long run
and when you look back around the film
that entire character just feels like
wasted time to pad on to the runtime
there's this whole thing with water they
keep cutting to water they keep
discussing water there's all these red
herrings in this movie these plot
devices that are thrown at you and you
think are they going to do something
creative or different nope it's just
going to be you got to kill a bunch of
people for no reason it's just
come on guys let's let's get some
creativity going here with such a cool
concept and that's for the ending of
course I won't spoil it but it just went
just ended and there were so many good
ideas I had such a great idea for how
they could end this and I was really
going to respect it because it seemed
like maybe it was going in that
direction and I don't want to get into
it because it's spoilers but it would
have given the film something to latch
on to we were like damn that really says
something and I thought it would have
been such a cool idea but they didn't go
a single place with it in the long run I
was disappointed in the Belko
experiments and I'm going to give it a
see this movie really could have been
something cool but they just went
nowhere with such a really great concept
and it's disappointing also I want to
make sure you guys know that my
promotion with Adam tickets is still
going on that's 8000m tickets if you
guys download this app to your mobile
device and you use my name Chris as the
promo code you'll get five dollars off
your entire order through the end of the
year it's just such a great mobile
device for buying tickets directly from
your phone you can even pre-order
concessions skip the lines so once again
if you guys do download the Adam tickets
app for your mobile device and use my
name Chris that's five dollars off your
order for the rest of the year which is
kind of insane really so definitely
thanks so much to Adam for continuing to
sponsor my videos you guys are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuntman eyes
[Music]